all right good morning i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i just want to quickly recap on why
we're here this morning
so yesterday morning at around 7 30 8
o'clock in the morning
we found the body of a young juvenile
out on state route 160.
the examination of the crime scene and
the victim's body
we immediately launched a homicide
investigation
since then we have worked continuously
and around the clock
trying to identify the victim
we are not here this morning with this
announcement if it is not for the
support of the community
your viewers in the media that has
assisted us
in the coverage that this has gained
as a result of that at around one
o'clock this morning
we were contacted by a mother who
observed this sketch
that mother stated that she was
confident that the sketch that we were
showing
was her eight-year-old son
from about or probably 90 minutes i
spoke with the mother on the phone
she shared photographs of her son and
as a result of that conversation early
this morning
we sent detectives to her house along
with the coroner's office
the coroner spoke with the mother
and the mother viewed photographs of the
deceased and made a positive
identification
that the child that was found yesterday
is her eight-year-old son
we also learned that the
victim was last seen leaving his house
at approximately 9 pm on thursday
evening
what we found out is that after leaving
the house he left with his biological
father
and first i want to well
he left with his biological father they
left that residence
and picked up another child who is his
half brother
the half brother is 11 year old
eden montez m-o-n-t-e-s
his photograph is directly off to my
left
that is the last time that eden
the eight-year-old or the biological
father of both
children have been seen approximately 12
hours after the last time they were seen
is when the discovery of the
eight-year-old's body was found
out on state route 160. at this point
we are actively looking to locate
eden montez we've had no contact with
him
family members have not found or had any
contact with him
nor have we had any contact with the
father
jose montez jose montes is 37 years
of age and is a las vegas resident
i'm going to share a photograph of the
vehicle that he is believed to be
driving
it is a 2015
white gmc pickup it has a nevada license
plate with las
vegas commemorative license plate lv
you like union the number or the letter
o the letter o again in x
like x-ray we are in the process
of beginning a multi-state amber alert
for the 11 year old child
that we are actively trying to find i
urge
your viewers and i urge all of you to
please continue to do what you have done
the success that we have located the
ident or
identified the victim again as a result
of
all the viewers and citizens calling in
these tips over the last several hours
or 24 hours please
if you have any information that leads
to where this vehicle
is please call 3-1-1
if you actively see this vehicle with
this license plate
please call 9-1-1 the vehicle again has
a unique sticker on the back
that says mr express you can see that on
the right
back windshield
i do want to share we do have some tips
that are coming in
if any viewers live in the sacramento or
fresno area
please be on the lookout for this
vehicle
also any viewers in the southern or
central utah area
please be on the lookout for this
vehicle we're getting a variety of tips
he does have connections in mexico
so again any routes that would lead
through arizona or california into
mexico
again please keep your eye out for the
11 year old again please
share all this information all the
viewers please share the post the
amount of eyes that we can get would
benefit this investigation we are still
manning a 24-hour
tip line that number is 702-828-3521
and we have started a second line of
702-828-2907
with that i'll take a couple questions
but again i'm still keeping a lot of
things very close to the chest in this
investigation
sean great um amber alert's very rare
of course can you please stress why
amber alerts are very rare why
people should be paying attention right
now they are very
rare and right now we are doing
everything that we can
to locate the 11 year old child eden and
we want to locate him alive
we know that he was last with his father
and
we now know that is in the same time
frame
that we have discovered the body of his
half brother so
i i can't urge the importance of this
amber alert
and again it's going to be a multi-state
amber alert just because we need to
locate him
brianna when jose picked up eden and the
eight-year-old can you say if it was
like a normal custody exchange
or is this like a parental kidnapping
situation it is not a parental
kidnapping
situation he's the biological father of
both children
and it's not uncommon for him to
take both children for weekends
in the back did the mother anybody share
any kind of relationship details that
might give you an indication whether
there was danger
or is danger i'm not going to get into
the specifics of that but there was
nothing that
indicated there was no alarming details
prior to this that would have caused any
serious alarms but i'm not going to get
any more specific than that
all right thank you guys i appreciate it
you